Mic Check yo welcome to another episode
of the full charge power hour a couple
of things you know the usual rate and
review us on iTunes donate at the full
charge com I get a CD out called this is
part of the job I hate on itunes and
spread the word we need your help we
want more people to hear this stuff or
maybe less people i don't know i'm going
through a midlife pakka podcast crisis
it's hard to say as you'll hear in this
episode but i don't know in the meantime
spread the word and come see me if you
live in california i'm at the paseo
camarillo camarillo cinemas I don't
really need to know what that is
hopefully you do Bolton Bolton
California gonna be there on the
twentieth of august and this paseo
camarillo cinemas on the 19th august
come on out I think these shows are
gonna be really embarrassing actually I
think it like we're not allowed to curse
or something I don't know what a
nightmare can't wait to retire but a fun
show coming up is uh the comedy night at
the end in Idaho let me try to pronounce
this poor dalene it's French you just
say it really quickly and you don't you
don't mention all the syllables or the
consonants go to lean in it's at a
[ __ ] best western haha oh my career
oh my career but I think it'll probably
be fun sky Alvin Williams runs it and I
think it'll be a lot of fun speaking of
fun our sponsor for the full charge
power hour is satva mattresses that's
saat VA and they've really made my son
and I think I don't think I'm ever
getting in another bed it's very
comfortable you can get
the firmness or the softness you want
you can order a to if you like it really
soft a one if you like it really really
soft you can order eight if you want it
really firm 10 is the firm is to get the
idea I got a 5 i'm kind of a little
ground kind of a guy but I've been
sleeping great even in this hot weather
I've been sleeping like a baby and a
sponsor of summer of charge it's just
been amazing you can go to smarter bed
com2 to get started with this and then
you'll get a call from their customer
service reps who are absolutely amazing
they have a full command of the English
language I've been trying to tiptoe
around this and say this without
offending anyone but they're their
people their customer service reps they
are very good at speaking English is
that is that a bad thing to say should I
have to say that you kind of do in the
modern age and I don't mean anything
against anybody all I'm trying to say is
satva is the best and you're going to be
happy with their customer service here's
the thing they got really cheap prices
and you like why they got such cheap
prices they're so good well here's the
thing they don't have any retail stores
it's all done over the internet you
check out what you want online and then
instead of helping them pay for their
store you just get to save the money and
you get the mattress that you want
without paying too much so what happens
is you order it and then they deliver it
to you and they come in and they set it
up for you it's not like a lot of these
other companies they'll just leave that
on your doorstep and you got to set it
up satva actually sets it up for you and
takes away as long as you let them know
ahead of time they will take away your
old bed and so you don't have to put it
on a curb you don't invite somebody over
an offer on pizza and beer you can just
like you just don't have to think about
you just mentioned you want your old bed
taking away and they will
it's amazing sattva smarter bed calm
these mattresses are hypo-allergenic and
eco-friendly so you know you might not
care about the environment but you are
going to care about your environment
this is your house you're talking about
your apartment you talking about and
they've gone extra lengths to make sure
that yeah it's not gonna be any
poisonous gases this is crazy mattresses
out there not satva the other guys but
it's just bad for your environment it's
bad for your air quality and sod so make
sure that you're gonna breathe healthily
you're gonna live healthily it's been a
word healthily health I don't know sup
it contains a patented spiral zone sleep
technology that will help reduce back
pain and stiffness I know my back feels
great and I gotta attribute that to the
mattress now what's really great is they
offer a risk-free 75 day in home trial
so you've got 75 days to figure out if
you'd like this thing or not what's that
two and a half months I don't know I'm
not good at math I'm pretty sure those
two and a half months to figure out if
you like it so it's risk-free you know
you're gonna you're going to know
whether you like to sing or not and
between me and you're going to like it
but you don't don't worry about it you
can return it if you don't like so go to
smarter bed calm and pick out a bed and
make sure that you select it you heard
about it from podcasts this company is
actually they're actually made of
podcast fans and they want to know who
is ordering because they heard it on
podcast podcast like your mom's house
and burn crushers podcast and of course
the full charge power hour let them know
you heard about it on podcast that's
smarter bed calm order yourself a SOT
foam mattress and now enjoy this episode
it's juicy oh it's a juicy episode I
hope you enjoy it later y'all
meet me at the icecream truck I'll buy
you some ice cream you know what I mean
the show was up scene but i'll bet you
go like these 3 News trying to get along
great Coleman and that [ __ ] wrong
don't forget to start the show be a job
Collin window let's go try to keep both
turn up the AC stage eating up eat it up
time to devour the full charge power
hour what's up yo welcome to the full
charge power hour some are charged and
full effects we got the white t-shirt
crew we got Craig Coleman hey now we got
kevin shea now guys tell us about your
new gang you've joined the white shirts
is called haynes not giving a [ __ ] the
haines hangman it's like um it's called
not giving a [ __ ] that looks pretty
clean and pretty pressed for you to be
nice oh god I I did laundry about a week
ago and I had let it pile and pile up
including my sheets and blankets and
towels cos his new place and I was
getting bit I had all these [ __ ] bugs
so I literally went to literally all
these [ __ ] but I went to the
laundromat on a sunday at six o'clock in
the morning I had take it anymore eight
loads not and not even in the regular
wash it it was those big the bigger it
was 60 pound washers isn't it great Wow
yeah isn't it great how your foster
parents paid all this money to bring you
to America and you're still living like
a third world yes my right foster
parents I tell you so about that word to
I don't like that you don't like that
word but it's a lot if you buy them the
no longer foster yeah I know I know I
know I know but for the sake of the
listeners I had to use the word role as
if I said your parents yeah you know
these are jokes here no no I want to
cover that today it's interesting i have
a great story about the word foster in a
second but yes i'm sitting in to laundry
at six o'clock in the morning sunday and
it's [ __ ] dude this I
I didn't even know if he was mexican or
filipino that pisses me off because i
feel like you don't like the movie la
Bamba I love that movie labelled Diamond
Phillips is Filipino yes yeah yeah no
way yep ya know about time it's about
time we told you Craig well I'm [ __ ]
highly disappointed Wow comes crashing
you know who else is Filipino is Rob
Schneider I I did after my shells last
night I shot at my youtube series and my
buddy said don't try not to be funny is
it a great line try not try not to be
funny so just be yourself enjoy not to
be funny right if that makes any sense
and I was like so you just want me to
talk [ __ ] yeah that's it so I did that
for an hour stock shipper now Lily for
an hour um the focusing all this guy's
you're probably like a minute out of
them yeah that guy standing next to me
he Lily's jokes people Joe dunk uh-huh
laundry stunk it stunk so [ __ ] bad
hmm and I just go and he laundrymat dead
three llow us yes it is it's like the
bus it's three loads in one [ __ ]
machine okay why do you [ __ ] sighing
you sighed and cough like your boy what
is the deal keep going okay [ __ ] this
guy yeah jokes jokes baby so just joke
people so he shoved all three was he
homeless no no not rocking the vibe know
how could you tell if he's homeless or
not yeah sometimes you have to ask the
dirt he had an iphone yeah but I've I've
ran into plenty of and it was a life if
I have yeah the dirt boy was an iphone 5
yeah thnkx over should i do do you got
you got the floor Kevin is that what you
were saying get there from for have a
iphone 5s Oh anytime I see someone
iphone 4 I think to myself oh yeah this
I'm rocking the iphone 4 Craig is poor
yeah Craig sport Matt now as an iphone 6
and then I'm like some recharge so you
telling me I was poor yesterday I'm poor
today I'm
rich even though I have less money sure
I bought an iphone so that's this thing
we got AC in the window but that's what
Apple does to you it's true yeah brings
you up and take you down its entire
society thing where I don't really need
I would really like uh somethin i'm
gonna tell you something yeah i was very
very very happy with my iphone 4 and i
didn't want to give it up oh but they
screw you out of enjoying your old
phones by not letting you download
certain apps on allocated equipment and
yeah it's [ __ ] up man just start
making this phone suck and you won't
yeah like there's two there's two apps i
really wanted uh-huh one uber I couldn't
get hoober on the [ __ ] phone I have
it I know you have it but mine was more
[ __ ] up I had to remember remember
like when you're supposed to upgrade to
seven point oh we're back wonder I
didn't do it back then and it became
impossible to upgrade yeah yeah there
wasn't enough room on my phone so uber
wasn't working and then on top of that I
I wanted to try this tinder and I gotta
tell you it's been nice knowing you guys
I'm gonna be spending the rest of my
time I'll piping left swiping right yeah
meeting people spur the moment what how
is that it's it's a lot of fun it
reminds me of the myspace days because
no one sweats my jock like they did in
the myspace day no just hit me up all
the time when the mice fell on my face
and now it's it's really cool you know
what girls feel comfortable doing it is
because you both have to agree that you
like each other before you can start
speaking to each other oh it's
impossible to hit somebody up until they
press like in your direction and so
girls are extra comfortable okay now I
was just one girl way too comfortable
she I don't think it was a real girl
what do you guys think I she texted me
she goes you seemed non-judgmental watch
me what did what does she look like she
looked like a like a brown-haired 20
year old chick okay and uh and said 20
and this is why I think she was baiting
me why because she didn't she didn't get
to know me at all she didn't as she just
her first message to me and I didn't
message her at all was hey you look
non-judgmental mmm [ __ ] that means
I've seen Harry meanwhile pictures
you've ever put out to 10 i wouldn't say
non-judgmental i would just say i don't
give a [ __ ] yeah ok yeah whatever I've
been putting all right no one's ever
called me non-judgmental before uh
especially the next door neighbors and
we'll get another second oh but um but
no no no no no but uh she's like text me
and and I go and I thought it was a scam
because we can easily talk right there
on tinder sure and we got into it for a
while and I go I was just flirting with
her and girls usually like flirts like
this I was like I was like I don't trust
you I'm not tax didn't you and she's
like what do you mean I go ahead give me
a break it's my first day on table why
would why why wouldn't you text her
because uh I I know there's no good
reason yeah I just was like well if you
like me let's flirt a little bit you
know what I mean she I I know what you
would do I like the immediately through
text cuz then if cuz you like talking to
dudes cuz I I feel like that's what's
happening well here's what i would do I
would text her a couple times what I
usually do and then i would call her and
then that right there sure that's
something she's interested that makes
sense yeah but i'm not always trying to
win Kevin I just wanted to [ __ ] play
first tinder experience I'm just trying
to get to know not trying to capitalize
every [ __ ] second of my life right I
just want i was selling sizzler trying
to [ __ ] figure it out Sarah and
Sheamus she goes she goes I go it's my
first day on tinder she goes I don't
even know what to say to that and I go
see you're being very judgmental I and
like I may be honest with you girls
usually like to like like fake fight and
flirt and shirt I don't know everything
but I do know that I wish I kind of want
to try tinder since you said it's like
myspace on a phone I think all right I
am shun be on tinder from what I
understand what was weird though is a
married guy from what i understand i
should not be nowhere near didn't even
know how to pronounce my eyes would be
happier if she found out you're on
Grindr my assumption with tender is it's
a lot more guys than women and the only
thing I know about like a bar sure yeah
like a bar the only thing I know about
tinder is every comedian as it ended
yeah yeah
last night there was seven comic yeah
and every single one had a convergent
yeah I couldn't believe it oh this don't
write a tender Joe I'm not even I have
one and I just got on it yesterday my
head I've been selling it for six months
but the joke is about like how I
couldn't get it on my phone okay right I
i I'm not on i was thinkin about ya
either or I don't know that now I
literally last night after everyone's
talking about i got on stage and I go I
don't have any of that stuff cuz i just
do cocaine I feel like it's the same
thing it's really the same it's like an
immediate thrill and then when you're
done you just want more of it right
right so that's it I I would like to try
tender I just feel weird cuz it it's
like dance no one has to know no I don't
want you don't want to go I don't want
spend money on these this one girl this
one woman she was like 48 she just if
you read her profile she's like hey not
[ __ ] around on here looking for my
last relationship and that she just
starts asking me all these like real
details about my life and I'm like I
wanted to be like hey I'm not I'm not a
guy I'm not the guy yeah I'm not the guy
she's like you have any kids what no I
don't even have a couch see this is this
is different than myspace it is like
good luck huh first of all girls that
are like extra cute really don't need
tinder no there's no this is like their
arse is like older women mostly okay I
hear there's hot chicks on tinder I'm
sure there are yeah but here's what's
interesting is like you're getting all
these weird questions on myspace was
nice because it was just my comedy
profile so they were just ask me some
questions about my show or jokes and
that was it that's the thing this is
like so lationship I know somewhere it's
still not my space somewhere along the
line comedies turned into something
dudes like definitely podcast no it's
just dudes writing me all day long no
offense guys but you have no vagina
whatsoever love to see if no matter how
hard you try I would love to see girl is
a guy I feel like we should call her
right now oh yeah that your thing with G
immediately like she immediately got rid
of you can like get rid of the message
you send on tinder uh-huh she like Rishi
she like revoked everything luxury Oh at
a certain point she said no what maybe
it is fake then she time I thought it
was fake yeah I don't know i don't want
some [ __ ] sleazeball having my number
sure i got along all of a sudden the
next question be like what's your last
name and all this [ __ ] dude she's L&D
amazin aim there's no reason we couldn't
hung out on tinder for five minutes
right there's no reason right there's no
reason without getting too I get it now
specific details yeah yeah how to hunt
you down and kill you and I'm like hey
I've had text messages for 10 years I
just got on tindr let's tender laughter
I get it is too it's totally hinder I
want to be on this yeah this girl's
going too fast definitely sounds like a
guy it's to quit was weird and she was
also very defensive about the things I
was saying really yeah I go I don't
trust you and she's like whew I like
girls like a little flirty like thank
you I trust me like it was funny is they
they like to be the with the [ __ ] the
prey oh sure they want to be chased but
it's also where when girls are too
aggressive I don't want anything to do
with it no it's too scary from it is
well your instincts go what the whole
doc is the old yeah I am I've also been
listening to a lot too much bill burr a
podcast and he's like paranoid about
everything yeah why would you give
anyone your information and that's like
just in my head now um that's good he's
the voice of the back yeah yeah hey come
on man machine like all the paranoia
those bills odd cuz I'll sit with him
once at lunch or something and he was on
the phone with the cable company right
and their ass information
and Lily 8 get and he goes why am I
giving you this information should have
it and I'm like this is how they set
your countdown why you need my address
can't you just do this down bill this is
how they do it that is fantastic I'm
gonna I'm gonna kill it on tinder though
because it's a picture of me in a suit
holding a Hershey's bars oh yeah I've
seen that what is that why I've seen
that you don't know about subs I was in
Hershey Pennsylvania yeah and I had a
huge Hershey bar that they gave Tosh and
I'm just old man in a picture I'm in a
[ __ ] great is a great picture day and
ah and uh it's it's subconsciously there
just be like yeah I want that [ __ ]
and you don't realize how much women
loved chocolate and sweets is that no
that's true and my all it doesn't of me
is crazy sweet hahaha that's funny do
you do you know what's funny is that
chocolate for that chocolate boy at the
hershey park is like 50 bucks yeah well
i got it all 30 50 bucks we're just
doing the trash you didn't try eating it
hmm it's like what half the size of
table oh you didn't even try eating any
of it i'll be trying to eat something
after a [ __ ] yeah
hey now cut that out that was a bad one
no I mean I just didn't want to eat like
I'd you know you ever you want them
[ __ ] solid ass Easter bunnies oh
they're all breaking off inside you
Scott yeah I was like let me get back to
LA get my dentist and then I'll eat this
[ __ ] candy bar to see this picture
now so if I it's on my facebook if you
go on tinder can i search for people you
can't you can't there's no last names
I'm not offered a picture and a first
name and yo I see how it can get Shady I
downloaded tinder a couple years ago
when one of the servers at the improv
emailed me a picture and she go sign on
so you can see me see more on tinder so
I did I go I don't want want to sign up
like I stopped at the process yeah cuz
you're like call it what I said like it
you gotta put a picture of sight no no
I'm the creep I just want I just know
you're right i want any interaction
there like now yeah i only want to see
this servers pictures right right she
does any human work to anymore that's
why i can say this but as I wanted and
her picture was like kinda like hot like
she mark the backwards upside down
picture so her head Yeah Yeah Yeah right
now we leave a classic yeah I was like
oh this is great I was like this is
gonna be great it's gonna be all these
hoes I can see all the old all right
they all right like not here to hook up
and then all I want to do is I girl yeah
and then they said we need a pellet
you're handsome that's like I don't want
a profile pic and then I just says they
just you just ditched it yeah I just
ditched it it's not worth it for me to
keep ya goin for it but now you let me
hook you with like a huge Clark bar or
something you know I mean we'll take
your picture will put a tie on ya know I
just get a little i'll be like men at
the men in black all of us here x I hold
of Hershey's kiss right I want to her
she's kissing or just say subtly sweet
yes m8 was it semi-sweet semi-sweet I'm
sweet in the morning all right after
that [ __ ] off oh um it's weird when you
see someone you know
on tinder because yeah yeah have you
come across three people I know already
is it just females hours it's just
females like that's that's what your ad
ins or they're sooo comedians in one
person I went to college with because it
so is based on zip code it's based on
zip code and they all live nearby I was
gonna say so late and there's nothing
like really wrong with them be on tinder
but it's like it is just weird
especially on the first day to be like
wow there's three people i think i think
a real rookie move would did like hit
like on people you know right right hey
wait they say Facebook writing is going
down right is good left is bad yeah so I
read an article about this couple who
was out on like they're like anniversary
date okay and they saw another tinder
date right an entire time they were on
the state this dude was on his tinder
tinder in front of this girl that's
awful like bragging about you know what
I much money had and stuff and then
apparently when she went to the bathroom
I guess he like texting one of the girls
from tinder yeah just like they're like
oh it's gonna go hook up right after
that I get why people do it I just I
like initial physical interaction sure
face-to-face for the first time mmm cuz
there's always a story like online it's
you almost it's almost too is you get to
well let's not forget let's not forget
that that's your specialty yes you you
show up this guy walks in he'd see
somebody who likes he walks right up to
them and starts talking to now that's do
you have any kind of fear whatsoever you
just don't cuz i immediately pick out a
flaw and i'm just saying oh she just
focus on that she's just like me not
perfect what's funny is it's nice man
that move that book the game I never
read it but when i told i think it's the
story on this podcast where the game if
you don't know the game is a book they
teach you how to pick up women yet teach
you a little technique niello browse had
me as a co-host for a radio pilot uh-huh
so i had to read some of the book and
i'm just like i got like 15 pages I'm
like I this is sure I've learned your
vice is already my [ __ ] my mo what you
do is you don't have to break the girls
down but mentally you just
need to say to yourself they're not
better than me she's gonna Club foot and
and if she's she chose you down so what
she's probably gonna like the attention
to that so what right I had a friend
like that he did not give a flying [ __ ]
he'd just go in and just [ __ ] hey did
it uh not be like whoa she's out of your
league he'd be like dude you seen my
face you know why people are out of my
goddamn aaliyah every time everybody
doesn't matter that guy got later oh it
doesn't matter I try not to bother women
in public places though sure like cuz
then it's like intruding nobody yeah you
do you do just walk up to people start
talking to us I do and the UN would
think about that because you're not even
hitting on them no you're just talk him
just talking nice yeah just like when
this [ __ ] shows up at the improv
first thing he does he walks any insults
the bartender tells him to give him
something before dinner insult him back
we have a [ __ ] we have a board too
that's an old-school relationship yeah
right so by the fifth drinky gives me
one for free nice because he's trying to
put you under this at all they should
all be sketches I know right Oh for
comics sure if you're on the [ __ ]
show you should at least get to not to
mention like we've been working there
for so many years now I've been working
there since 2001 right there's no clubs
I think I think if you're a little
bigger they will shirts funny is those
guys don't have the money they don't
need free drink Yeah right well it's
just like the rock bands when you're big
or you're somebody everybody gives you
free [ __ ] right free adida is free
whatever they just send you boxes of
shoes and shirts but when you're the
broke-ass band no one's giving you jack
I was in I was in Vancouver last week in
this guy came to me is like I heard your
skateboarder i'm gonna give you all the
skateboarding equipment and I was like
that's called k got his business card or
whatever and the girl next means like
you a [ __ ] that never gets old and I'm
like first time it ever happened it's
never get so actually does happen every
once in a while but that's like some
small ass potatoes like hey dude give me
a costco card I flip out but think about
these drinks think about these drinks of
the improv they're just sitting there in
the keg yes I cost eight cents yeah
that's it like cost them not to be ours
what they should do is keep us separate
ok like the cheap right when it's all
right achieve castle natural light like
people give free popcorn like you you
guys get a drink yet I don't draw VA on
tab I don't drink cheap liquors cuz I
have a lot of allergies but they should
have like a really cheap section I like
cheap liquors this my mother [ __ ]
problem no shows enough [ __ ] problems
so they they just have that for the
comics yeah or two dollars sure yeah
just the cheap yeah chief will drinks
yes done so what's with the UH well so
part of summer of charge so part of
summer charges uh you know having fun
right and kevin shea he's my sidekick
Christian chillin yeah or I'm his
sidekick are you okay just uh no no it's
fine in the ears from the okay um so Joe
DeRosa had a birthday party on Monday
and it was we have the same birthday me
and Joe DeRosa okay and so I'm like well
this is my birthday party too you know
okay nothing really nothing really
outstanding about that party except for
there was a shitload of people there
okay it was a shitload of peace and um I
have plenty of drinks we had a funny we
had a funny experience on the train ride
oh yeah we took the train there no no
also now make no mistake i got the dope
ask chrysler 300c now sure but I've
learned so much from my life in your
days without my my days on foot there's
a lot of places you can take on the
metro the LA metro is underrated
especially I'm Jay oh and you live a
block away frock Oh train station then
yeah then it's a you can drink but be
during the day oh you don't have to [ __ ]
with trap now it's all SAT all that goes
everywhere you're probably gonna yeah I
couldn't believe it we show this is two
stops so Matt's like this is awesome
there's no one here so we went down I
forgot about those yeah we're going down
the long quiet Escalade which one are
you riding the vermont and sunset my
that's a gnarly one okay and I call like
this I go man I could imagine being a
girl being on a date doing this cuz it's
too quiet write a two desolate for
something to go down yeah it's
can we get straight a rubdown shut up I
will be final did you record it now so
we went down and pass taking everyday be
fine don't worry though you're cool
yahoo I like you fit right in plus I was
like I love any money what he gonna do
is look for iphone 6s so we standing
there I go it must be hard for a girl by
herself and there was only one girl way
and there's maybe 10 people sporadically
uh-huh she comes walking over to us and
we're like oh it says right next to Matt
and she goes I didn't see her walk over
I see this cute little face down so
funny yeah she was only Gaza l she's
coming over maybe she's waiting for she
goes can I stand next to you guys is
that bill safe yeah yeah because there
was some lunatics literature oh yeah no
I've worked at [ __ ] station yeah
you're so right right razy [ __ ]
down there and it's true you don't
exactly have to buy a ticket to use this
metro so anybody can they built right in
no they are you gonna do take away my
rights I'm home yes they work the
turnstile yeah not a yelling at each
other yep they were I could tell they're
homeless OOP two black dudes what I want
you to walked over if the two black
dudes really hell yeah you can stand
here [ __ ] like we're really civil i
think i think the shouting really really
really had a lot yes it did I think
crazies always a stronger influence than
racism yes so we're haha oh yeah crazy
wins every time exactly come here of
crazy o crazy yeah that's your like
loose cannon so don't want to be near
that we talked to her for a second or
like this train is usually dead yeah
usually there's no one here and this
[ __ ] train rolls up is packed is
packed i was like on o'clock at night i
go the most vinicky this hot dumb i am
is how non-sports i am still I must have
been a kings game it ain't hockey season
is it the summertime right and then I go
dodgers game and that's like but there's
no that doesn't go to the way the
Dodgers say them again yeah we're in LA
so it's like it should never be [ __ ]
hockey season here anyway I'm like
lakers you know there's some days you
get on the train and everyone was
in a kings jersey hilarious is so funny
it's like kings nation so this do comes
out with a Bernie shirt Bernie we get on
the train oh oh yeah he comes out his
speech yeah we didn't know that so on
yeah I start laughing matter I go I
can't believe they already have a Bernie
shirt out cuz the whole Facebook thing
ya know test I know I can't believe they
already have this and I go who's that
and he tries to explain and as he
explained it like I couldn't even get my
head around the explanation I was a UH
this girl turns around yeah it was
packed it was packed and I go like the
single he's the Facebook guy who is him
and the [ __ ] lion that's on facebook
now because of the protesters yeah and
the girl turns around she goes this is
actually we're coming from a Bernie
convention yeah a bird and then you
start looking around and everybody's
wearing a Bernie patch a Bernie shirt
right Bernie Bernie car key chain there
is some like 60,000 people when I say
that mother files a broker record the
face the facebook thing helped yeah he's
uh any he's like is the dude for
minority rights and he's for everybody
he's for the working class so what was
funny as soon as she said i go i got'em
agawam what is he any bad about that
yeah no kidding today and I wanted to I
yeah you about so you got stink eye
that's it yeah liberals so none of them
would have been like what you said I
would have said I wanted to say how is
this do gonna [ __ ] run the country
when it can't handle two women protest
he's part of the Facebook generation you
can't be mean I'm serious like how the
[ __ ] is he gonna run a country it's like
70 years old like he literally backed
away like the football coach award let
me put it to you this way he backed away
from to Black Panther chicks yeah most
people would you you ever been
confronted by an angry black chick yes
yeah get the all right I know but here
yeah your regular dude but he's also
he's not let me ask you this I view our
own stage doing comedy and two black
chicks started yelling at you would you
back away I dropped the mic oh you would
know you
watch differently I'm doing stand-up but
this is the same thing nice guy yeah
this guy's running for president yeah
better for him to shut out black chicks
not shove what he does is goes hey what
is your name and then what is your name
yeah you they weren't having it those
chicks were not having well he should
have said something just walked away cuz
it might mean it was this guy can't
handle those no no it should have
happened security sure to grab you
should have had some security to wait
whoa no one's got it all gauge and my
like me is a site rep that wouldn't a
[ __ ] hell [ __ ] no here's a cracks me
up my second thought was when I saw that
was with the girl could you imagine
being this chicks boyfriend or
girlfriend oh my god oh man sir is now
embarrassing the answer is [ __ ] know
when fight the power turns into your the
power he has fighting that's no fun but
just let her speak letter speaker was
shut this [ __ ] down right now if it was
funny be funny like Kanye West
interrupting taylor street and then it's
just her pops up let her speak where i
shut this [ __ ] down like they were so
angry like it was almost detrimental to
their calls cuz it turned me off to
their cause I was like I give a [ __ ]
well I was busy cuz they went after the
one guy who actually gives a [ __ ] so
[ __ ] your by the way if you guys heard
that everyone's like not really into
Trump but excited about what Trump is
bringing to the table at these debates
have you heard that like I've heard all
these open minded people say hey I ain't
vote for Trump but this is fun as [ __ ]
oh he's fun he's the voice of ignorance
yeah yeah Oh big time it doesn't give a
rat's ass quick you know he doesn't care
about the presidency he's [ __ ] he's
winning don't know he's winning cuz he's
gonna use this for his next show
absolutely his next stunt there's
already a celebrity's winning here it
doesn't have to win he doesn't have to
become he doesn't want to because I
resident genius no [ __ ] way that guy
what's up got some pay cut it's a pay
cut and it's a pain in his ass he
already wait you beat that guy
to get woke up at one in the morning go
hey dude some shits going down over in a
Cairo like what so well you're the
president you need to give a [ __ ] that's
I love any politician that refers to
himself in the third person he does that
yeah he's like Trump's gonna take care
of that sack so [ __ ] [ __ ] it's
hilaire I gotta be honest to you I
didn't Batman talks like that I have no
issue with that man should run I have no
issue with Trump not because if anyone
takes him seriously it's like you're a
fool you're taking the Kardashian series
right your take angry with that that
[ __ ] monster of a daughter that Ozzy
Osbourne has o monster Osbourne that's
her name she [ __ ] heroes and PES part
of carries on my kelly osbourne Kelly
I'll but what is she up to these Oh it
in here I don't pay attention to any
courtesy I don't either her station
popped up on the radar she was on some
TV show and she was trying to be on the
people who hate trunk yeah and she said
will trump if all the mexicans are
kicked out of your country who's going
to clean the toilet oh my right and
people were like hey how about you just
don't talk you're not how hard waiting
for an audit applause but she thought
she was yeah she thought it was a mighty
rod and Rosie present something and
they've got into her about it and she
goes don't involve me in this I'm not
involved with this argument yes actually
use just clearly said that yeah I'm not
him just dropped that you just created
all right that is so like my uncle used
to say when I was a kid he's Mexican he
would say you know without us mexicans
whitey would [ __ ] starve right could
you know pick all their fruits and
vegetables yeah now he can say that and
she could have certainly worded it a
better way way better just the way she
[ __ ] you go you go the economy could not
exist without the Latino sure off is
very well that uh rich kid rich kid all
that I did well that's my thing I'm like
you dumb [ __ ] you didn't even grow up
poor like your [ __ ] dad yeah she grew
up bridges the not that that expensive
education just really no vocabulary came
with that yeah right she's [ __ ] a
monster yeah she's so gross but
the thing is I people were mad I'm like
why why you why you shall you expect
someone like her to say and why do you
care and why do you give a [ __ ] I don't
care I think you sees these kids is
Facebook these kids in these like
celebrities or whatever you want to call
them now that there's all the social
media you're exactly right they all want
to be hot for the day mm-hmm like the
cool kids in class are like really
competing to be cool every day and
relevant every day because it's such a
temporary thing now like everyone's on
to the next thing like bring up Cecil
the lion in two years and see if anyone
knows what I'm going to talk about and
all it's not like it's not like the
funny the funny thing about Cecil the
lion is like the people that were
bitching about they weren't vegetarians
I don't trust those right these people
like you should have done it either but
right guy should be like eating chicken
sandwiches your [ __ ] type in this
year I don't trust those people who
protested the dentist because those
people have those people are the ones
that were supporting the cops shooting
the kids and supporting like against gay
marriage so they had nothing two were
they the same though I don't know that's
my assumption is in my head is like so
they don't really have a really good
cause so they chose this one my guess is
those people love it when black kids get
shot we're gonna give a [ __ ] what I
really hate nowadays is I found out all
my news on Twitter I know some people's
opinion I know I'm like lion then you
gotta go google some [ __ ] to go don't
care if you care fair enough right I
never googled it I just watched
everybody [ __ ] about it and I'm like
who killed a lion I finally a douche for
sure lion of course I of course I think
that but like everyone's got to get
upset about it everyone's gotta write
about it III didn't even think he was a
douche about it no I think it's an
[ __ ] thing I think is [ __ ] up with
you to jiraffe what you see in rhinos
I'm like why all that you have I'm right
I got friends that hunt yeah live in
alaska every year it's moose season they
go get a moose it's elk season they go
get it moves cuz they're feeding the
[ __ ] family you're gonna have lions
in Africa [ __ ] no I think I almost
Polly's
where did you say what if they have lion
season ever ah I think I Carillo season
that would be awesome big [ __ ] that
gorilla of it is all around me hey I
think all right yeah you can hunt
gorilla but you can only bring a knife
yeah now that's that a good Ian believe
it I don't and the monkey has a knife
like here's the thing with that guy that
guy was a douche before the hunted he
was absolutely think I was a dentist
yeah I Jewish bag gift is Dabangg but it
got me was i I get it it looks horrible
but like all these celebrities coming
out I'm like white why are these
celebrities talking about these lines
but they kept their mouth shut when I
came to real [ __ ] that's the part that's
marked on that democrats and liberals
they always rally around the wrong
[ __ ] pole and I'm like why do we give
a [ __ ] about this yeah and they were
they scream all you need to get rid of
potatoes cuz of the carbs and just [ __ ]
that I'm like ha ha we give a [ __ ] about
something that matters yeah I gotta give
a [ __ ] what other people eat and drink
this is why I'm scared alliance yeah
yeah I am too i don't think i know about
lines is the movie and and that poor
love movie lion king and that i haven't
seen it it's poignant yeah it is
poignant and that poor lion that sits at
the MGM Grand in the entranceway between
the casino oh how board is that [ __ ]
guy [ __ ] poor line a sin that he's
above you here in this big glass
encasing and you look up and you just
see this big he's gotta you gotta listen
to it didn't
I feel worse for that lion and Cecil
yeah at least sisa went down yeah if
you're gonna shoot a line down she show
that one yeah put it out of its goddamn
misery so here's the thing that's worse
that's actually worse that's worse life
and what did dentist did for sure that's
my issue I agree at least this lying
went out in the wild he was gonna eat
this [ __ ] hyena for this jackal they
dragon at least he thought he was going
down like a man right Jim BAM he's
[ __ ] death like mobster salt like in
the back of the head yeah [ __ ]
japanese torture are you sitting in a
[ __ ] casino glass box right just
eating the way so people should protest
MGM yeah there you go there you know but
there you go so I love gambling you
can't save Cecil go save that guy yeah
so when those protesting MGM by
downloading their movies for free all
summer long oh yes taking money out of
their pockets he admitted to this yeah
he's a minute to in the podcast you sure
I've admitted to it yeah yeah my online
is back so I'm about to you do not know
what's crazy is uh with all the online
[ __ ] right the this year has been the
most profitable year in movies and no
that's they're still making money that's
good money is still make a tunnel I
don't have an issue with stealing this
[ __ ] I don't either well especially
since they won't let us play we've been
denied by these people for decades now
have been denied yeah so far you ain't
gonna put me in any movies I'm gonna
steal all yours so suck my dick am I
feeling am i stealing from tosh point-o
know those [ __ ] hook me up do
you am i stealing from marvel [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah yeah you know what my dick if it
ain't on netflix I'm what ok [ __ ] you
then yeah download right I mean I I urge
everyone there listening this to
download this podcast for free all right
don't pay for it that's right damn it so
we go to this party and it's a good time
ok were there for hours alright get a
safe ride home from Jobar neck oh nice
he doubles as a bodyguard nice and you
know is he a big guy it was huge he's
the man he looks totally unknown
he's all night she's so nice and so huge
uh so the next day we decide we're gonna
go to the the all things comedy show at
the comedy store okay and I'm gonna go
pick up kevin or you want it no we're
just gonna go see cuz burr is hosting oh
and that's just the [ __ ] [ __ ] a you
get to walk right in and watch burr do
some comedy right finally a perk to
being a regular at The Comedy Store girl
there you go and uh I'm walking out this
door oh here the apartment yeah and and
the dog just starts barking like yeah
easy right did you park back no no
because I've seen you do it before you
quality I've done it before last time i
left the Duggar for Rudy whoa whoa okay
please oh so I'm walking out the door
this is the best and she's like she's
like I'm mad at you but I can't hear to
you yeah cuz that she's way over there
by this table right over there okay and
she's like I'm mad at you but I can't
really hear cuz the dogs barking so loud
right we even thinking she was talking
to you I was like nine you she's telling
me couldn't he what she was saying yes
she's looking at me talking Oh like
overthrow her and she says I'm mad at
you and I go oh [ __ ] I got water i did i
do something left yeah we think i drag
did I jerk off with the door open or
something which would be great summer of
discharge um um so she's like I she goes
listen to your podcast and I got whoa
yeah downloading it listening to it or
listening to us doing it listening y'all
yeah cuz you specifically talk [ __ ] now
I'm whispering you better talking me we
talked of me oh yeah I did several times
we're still whispering and so I still I
still I go [ __ ] awkward uh
immediately you're you're [ __ ] crazy
lady ok let's hear this but please don't
shout it no what tell me why you think
that that's [ __ ] crazy ok that's like
will you go with this guy so explain to
me why explain to me why in stalker cuz
first of all she has to find out who the
[ __ ] you you know what in there no this
no no no it's not not that bad because
it's different because here's what
happened here's what happened ok and
you're very very vulnerable once you
start doing like oh I'm on the UM I
haven't had it come back to me well I'll
just listen mate the the the first they
wouldn't even know I was a comic but
kevin was staying here while I was gone
he was house-sitting for me ok and I
goes right this is kevin bubble how do
you guys know each other well we work
together I cuz I'm a comedian and that's
when ok that's when like interest starts
you know oh that made you interesting
right yeah so the other day I ma I'm
making t-shirts in the garage which by
the way I saw some kid at the party and
he introduced me he introduced since we
introduced ourselves to each other
because I know you are man and I'm like
really he's like yeah you bet poster on
your lysing you make a DJ's out on the
street what out of the ICU that's really
weird what's not really around it's not
really weird when you're famous no yeah
yeah he lives with Manning the [ __ ] up
no you know you know you know what's
funny is I was only out there for about
four hours though the whole city must
have seen me you know it this is a
pretty this is a thoroughfare people
coming ya know there's there's there's a
small group of people who know who I am
he just happened to be one of that yeah
that absolutely makes it um on the other
hand I'm amazing how many comics that
live in LA don't know don't know
this is humiliating it's just know I'm
fo r yo u comma you stand up oh hello
yeah yeah yeah we're still in high
school all right so okay so so ok ok so
so here's what happened so dude comes by
and we start talking shop and everything
and he goes and they also asked us what
are you guys doing in there all the time
we say we're doing a podcast oh wait
you're talking up these people or the
dude that bumped into you at the party
it's not about these people right ok
right and so eventually it comes around
last week hey uh what's name your
podcast oh but I'm thinking I'm thinking
a no one ever listens to [ __ ] no one
dude how many do you have to listen to
you to find you a lot because I think
there's only two there's a seriously
just one episode yeah there's not that
many where we talk smack wow the
marathon through like my wife got bored
after four she's just like good good
good she was like I got enough I got a
happy so we never hit a point where she
was like hey dude right why are you
talking about that so as it's going down
I know I I don't I don't I don't really
I know I just I just go I just I just
immediately yeah yeah keep God's good
but I can't [ __ ] so uncomfortable like I
would be so uncomfortable so I
immediately liked apologize and I I
explain why I explain why I'm sorry I
say I never thought you listen to it and
it's very important to me that we keep
friendly relationship and I sincerely
apologize I smooth because that's
exactly how I tell you fry exactly how I
really yeah cuz I was trying to explain
to the wife and other people i'm like
'look jokes jokes on stage about our
marriage being awesome and cool yeah
aren't funny weird right yeah yeah
people so and that's another thing is
just like a really weird thing and it
when i was talking to kevin in the car
afterwards i was i was talking about
this i was talking about like
what is this podcast really worth to me
sometimes because um you have to but you
have to do that you have to do this as
you do it under your name right and
there and there your thoughts now what's
what the difference between you with the
mics off and you with the mic so on is
you talk about things that are
inappropriate to keeping and maintaining
a healthy relationship right so in the
name of because then otherwise what else
is there to talk about yeah I like the
stuff I talk that will joke around with
and I got my friend Ronnie it's yeah
that's the most Ross [ __ ] ever that I
would never say in public only Ronnie
right and so it's appropriate to say it
on this podcast some degree I'm
questions questioning some degree right
but it's not appropriate to say in real
life and then people that know you to
whatever level listen in and they go
yeah they think they think these are
things you're dying to say that are on
your mind all the time that actually
have a place in the relationship and
they don't they're just little things
that bother you right sure but I can't
really explain that and I didn't even
bother I didn't even have those ideas it
was that was the next 24 hours of
suffering that I came up with that that
apology or like like a death so Matt
without ya I went through the five
stages of grief I went through the five
stages of grief I went through like uh
except i went to a definitely go through
a depression and then all like 24 then i
started going through like an anger and
i was i was on the phone with with kevin
and i was i was upset i was upset and he
goes here he goes you going through all
these phases agree when I go you go he
goes is like something died I go yeah
it's uh yeah you're so right he goes
it's like something he goes it's like
something died ago yeah it's uh me being
comfortable at home just as his comfort
diet it's uh but I told him when he told
me I go [ __ ] it you did the right thing
right don't be ashamed of it this is
entertainment uh if she out if she lie
anything though I'll be
i I don't I don't feel bad anymore no
you really but at the end whenever
initially happened I've I just got that
principal's office feeling all that I
haven't that I haven't had since I was a
relationship with a woman which is you
busted home [ __ ] up and I got a good
idea I thought I totally be great if we
had her on ok ok ok ok ok kkkkk huh
we're probably gonna cut this off at
this point I'm probably gonna cut this
out but we can still talk about her see
I I don't feel comfortable inviting her
at all because she she's cheating she is
this one not this will not be on the
podcast but I'll tell you she went and
got my phone number from the landlord
whoa which is not cool for my landlord
to do he can't give you that it
shouldn't give what I did what a dick
okay and I'm glad he did initially
because she texted me and said hey
everything's cool I was just kidding
with you we're all good we can keep this
in um like in my in my in my world it's
only happened a few times I got
recognized once and target well nice we
r and we standing next to the product
you were advertising that would have
been great no is it random we were even
in north hollywood target in this girl
oh she goes oh my god she goes be my
husband saw you in Santa Monica you know
at our basement show yeah she was you do
comedy here from Bakersfield right I go
yeah not like Karen hey [ __ ] and then uh
you know at random and a few other
people yeah well I you know I used to do
in Newport I used to go down there and
do comedy all the time yeah but our
lives never cross my sister would bring
her friends out yeah you know they're
all teachers right she's a teacher so
all her friends or teachers and all
these hot teachers she's nice all right
yeah it's hilarious and that's a very
abstract idea but it's getting me horny
right it is so so so Karen it is so
Karen starts working out there a new
port in the school district um and then
people start oh I'm summers a
sister-in-law yeah and they're like
Oh your husband's a comedian you're
married to summers brother right and
Karen's like oh yeah if you know my
comedy Disher LSD mad right just like
[ __ ] not clean or proper yeah and so
she always has that initial yeah like
has did like how do you feel about that
like I'm not my husband and then luckily
they always go oh he was hilarious it
was great and you're like okay cool huge
relief cool they're not stiff lay my dad
my dad was talking the other day and
he's like somebody came up to me and
they're like hey you uh John Folse
Ronnie you Matt full Sean's dad and he
goes out he goes I started gearing up
cuz this could go either way that's
fantastic I didn't know who you were
whoa God it was actually someone that
actually knew me oh ok but like I've
been walking down my street that 10
people live on my parents live on the
street where 10 people live there and
I'm going to get the mail I'm telling
you there's not even anybody on me
there's not even anybody on the other
side of the street right there's not
even a pair on one side apparently did
in the other side of street hasn't been
sold yeah somebody's hanging on to that
property because they're keeping it real
right I know what I'm saying nothing
built on it nothing right trying to
preserve Southern Maryland as dudes
walking his dogs big [ __ ] he's
walking his dog and he goes he was a I'm
so-and-so cuz that's how it goes in the
small town aha neighbors everyone knows
each other they know my parents and I
got ya I'm Matt and he like jolts like
energy goes through him he looks at me
in the face like he goes and it just
locks on he's like yeah that's Matt and
he goes you think you the comedian I go
yeah because a maybe I'm too old or
something but I do not get what you do
oh my he said that to you
a to your face you know what and he
knows your parents that's what it is but
I don't think people know that that's
like in summary no but people who know
you or the family sure they think it's
fun it's okay to say that kind of yeah
but if you said something about their
job or their life they would lose their
mom yeah they don't understand yeah but
I always think it's great that I got
heckled in the woods mind of my own
bills that's great heckled in the woods
i think i'm saying i just said I'll take
that as a compliment I walked inside
yeah when I was I wasn't mature enough
like I was actually got like really
possum I you fat [ __ ] friend out
there yeah blah and then my dad goes
will we think you're funny i'm like [ __ ]
you yeah that's even worse and again he
didn't know my dad's the coolest guy in
the world he was trying to be cool right
the guy out in the woods not trying to
be cool well yeah what's your comeback
to that guy you're like oh you don't get
it says guy who lives on the street with
ten [ __ ] people [ __ ] you know that
would have been awesome after you see
that you had a walk four more blocks
with him yeah I know in the wood I'd be
great that is just awkward just awkward
the whole way I would have been like so
what then what don't you get let's make
it down is so to drill in him and making
a point where he feels awkward he's like
I should just kept my [ __ ] mouth sure
that's how you know you know it's funny
though is like back then it was really
before social media took off and now i'm
used to get my nuts handed to me on the
day so i just realized i had every day
and I and Shay's always been cool with
it what you've always been cool with
like people Boston you better stand back
yeah I don't have an issue yeah I ice
weird is I don't know if I'm not as
relevant as I think I i know i'm not
that relevant but i don't get that many
hate tweets I don't anymore uh I'll get
which means we're not relevant yeah
we're not relevant popular abortion boy
yeah i'll get one girl after every show
okay sure they come up to you and they
want to do but that's flirting for women
are you yeah I don't know came up to me
one time she's like your kind of funny
I'm like your kind of attractive ah my
game started to get stuff that's so why
I got I got my cousin [ __ ] me up the
other day she she's one of these posts
all her [ __ ] and she says uh I have
insomnia can't sleep when I say hey I
listen to audiobooks the Bible is my
go-to that's funny knocked the [ __ ] out
three minutes I did yeah deuteronomy's
you know and Jeff begotten Tia and Tina
begotten Jethro so she writes back maybe
I should listen to your comedy go oh
yeah that's nice I go oh nice not I want
to be like hey [ __ ] you you fat redneck
[ __ ] Oh last you and your [ __ ]
husband you can't but you can't you've
gotta take it you can't as long as
people play by the rules you can't step
you can't stand up that hot I usually
just I usually don't reply or just say
thank you right I go make sure you buy
my CD so I a loser diet you gotta smile
through the [ __ ] or else you lose no
last night I was kind of a big brother
this girl comic went on and her name's
Heather and she was kind of having a
ruff said it was a rough [ __ ] room
there was 46 people yeah regular people
right Oh in the crowd yeah this these
two dudes come in and they were
obviously gay i'm sitting in the back do
you know where the grand star is
downtown Chinatown is actually [ __ ]
awesome so Chinese jazz club okay so
they come and ask me that can we sit
anywhere we want I said yeah I don't I
don't work here I'm [ __ ] it in the bag I
go
oh my god so this guy hop sing uh make
sure you buy my CD and it's always funny
and is made even funnier they're very
gay right if you tell black one and I
think the other one was [ __ ] white
one half Mexican right yeah gay black
guy was nice and the school goes on half
of the Mexican was nice this girl goes
up and she is uncomfortable cuz there's
no one there sure and the people up
front they were lyk soos I found out
that a night they were industry and
wanted to [ __ ] lease it right in
front cuz industry love failure so yeah
they do think I've seen a bunch of
industry at a public house just [ __ ]
on a show before why would you just like
six guys commentary six guys in suits me
like disco buddy sucks they were like
young guys you didn't get that like out
out comedy was done yeah yet there's a
lot of shitty rooms you mean they were
[ __ ] on the out loud yeah yeah yeah
they were heckling the whole deal oh so
this school goes on and she goes the
half-mexican one goes the other one goes
hey she needs to write some better jokes
oh yeah and I'm like damn I'm saying
they get mad and she go first of all you
ask me where to sit and then yeah I know
you bein a dick and then she goes to the
guy she he goes you're funny she goes oh
yeah thank you and you know no small
rooms yeah especially like I don't know
how long she's been doing it sure you
start to get insecure 11 on stage and
she goes oh thank you and she goes
you're funny-looking right she said that
bad all the [ __ ] dudes no I was
pissed oh dude son said you're funny set
her up yeah funny looking at and then
she did you she and then was the best
part is she had a great set after that
though uh-huh no she got wish I had my
god and she [ __ ] demolish here's what
here's what hecklers don't know we can
spit on you yeah hey we got some
leverage on you mom she did a whole bit
about how she [ __ ] hates men cuz it
dudes like him you're the dude that is
either the [ __ ] and there's the pro
feminist dude who's just trying to
[ __ ] me
ha laughed so hard at that and she had
some female book references I had no
[ __ ] sure right right it's all the
notebook to moon yeah yes so she so I
went walked around and I was ready to
[ __ ] yep malish this guy but I didn't
she handles so i set the back she gets
all the book lately and the black
boyfriend right I could be wrong it but
they seem pretty gay he was like this
make us I'm so sorry about my racquet
once again I don't work here you said
that to you he goes we can leave now I'm
like good but once again now apologize
to apologizing like to the wrong party
you don't have to tell me that you leave
me cuz I don't know here all right oh
[ __ ] by the way real quick before we
leave this okay go ahead here with the
situation next door are you gonna do a
fruit basket we talked about that um I'm
don't apologize you're down apologize i
do think it was a weird scam and i do
think it was first of all I think it's
kind of ok to listen but I don't I don't
like it even if I said nothing about
them I don't like my next door
neighbor's knowing everything about you
gonna edit now again yeah again that's
my fault you for doing this can we do it
but another point another point is um
you know you don't have to really
confront me about it because that's when
she's better to just hate you that's
when [ __ ] starts he didn't hate me
quietly yeah ok can we do a joke about
this real quick I want to do the guys go
ahead but please don't be loud about it
no I won't how's it I have to I I have
to have to live are you gonna are you
gonna get the neighbors I guess I don't
have to well it's a good spot I could
leave in a second you can leave swell on
tour with all this money all this one
take it easy all right I know you got a
phone i got a CEO and come on what is
left he sees an air conditioner and a
second hand flat screen yeah he thinks
I'm I'm rich yeah which is not mounted
it's leaning I'm ah I'm all running for
president they charge for bomb Mexico
will charge will bomb Afghanistan I can
you should get him a fruit basket but
not a real one cuz you don't want it to
be too sympathetic as it is your show so
I told mad like maybe she get him a
block of cheese and apple her Oh like
something that was already in my fridge
he said he said something's already my
fridge already unwrapped yeah and like a
couple crackers and just a funny gesture
so just to keep it awkward after the
show is awesome bill burr was awesome um
afterwards I got a ticket and I want to
call my attorney right now you got a
ticket from what a parking ticket I want
to call my attorney or give me I got a
new phone but I want to call my attorney
Ryan stout who never pays a ticket
without a fight how much time does Ryan
had so he can do that Oh what he takes
it to the limit we're all comics do we
got it we got afternoons free but any
ticket even in the mornings when you're
parking somewhere when you're not
supposed to that's why I want to call
you know what I mean because I'm the
type of guy that just pays it right he's
all not the type of doesn't Brian what
Batman mad fool around here with kevin
shea and my car was Craig Coleman no sir
I didn't know kevin was gonna be
involved I don't want to do this okay I
can do this race luck I'm so at The
Comedy Store on Monday night I I got a
parking ticket and I actually how cry I
actually paid actually paid the meter
and I know I'm in the wrong i paid the
meter for two hours and you're supposed
to move your car after that and then I
paid for another two hours so
technically I paid for it but I was
there for four hours and was only just
to be there for two hours what are one
of my rights what am I rights here um
well the parking enforcement is a whole
different thing rum oh yeah I'm speeding
speeding tickets and trap
yeah cuz you actually go to court for
traffic tickets parking enforcement is
like a municipal code type things I've
to fight those [ __ ] and they are
worse than the courses so you're saying
just pay the ticket um I mean you know
what's nice is you you haven't admitted
any wrongdoing to anybody usually if
somebody gets pulled over by the cops
you know the cops like you were on your
cell phone and I end up like kind of
throwing themselves under the bus so
like look I was just making a quick
phone call they end up admitting guilt
right and then when they go to court the
cop says yeah the guy said he was
talking on the cell phone um fortunately
you haven't talked anybody so I don't
know how they can how they have evidence
that you were there longer I mean they
could have taken pictures of your
vehicle hey chocolate but the chalk it
yeah they chalk it yeah I don't take
pictures of it they might no need here's
the here's the problem with the parking
tickets what happens is they make you go
to some sort of administrative hearing
but just by attending that hearing you
have to sign a piece of paper saying the
ticket is prima facie evidence against
you now they make you agree to that so
basically what they do is they make you
sign a piece of paper saying yes I'm
guilty until proven so welcome to
America Ryan do you live in it and make
you prove your innocence right you can't
do it because number one you're guilty
right you know yeah they just put you in
a bad position you're sitting across a
table from some woman who had like 20
hours of training and that training
consisted of the Elk Rapids job right of
doing a quote review right how is the
problem with that is the only thing she
knows about the law is whatever the
person trained her told her right I i
use a woman as the example can i argued
with the plate in with okay look what
you see you see the [ __ ] he had to do
he hadn't mentioned why was a woman in
his
[ __ ] story right yeah yeah yeah I
said yeah I'd back that up so while we
got you on the phone um just and you got
into it a little bit just for the
listeners a couple pieces of advice for
when you get pulled over by the cops
just um well first of all we have to say
this is not legal advice since I'm not a
lawyer right this is just an adjustment
just my only right um if you get pulled
over by a cop first of all don't say
anything well don't try to talk your way
out of it no don't don't apologize all
you have to do is provide your license
registration and insurance okay so ask
you any questions you just say I'm sorry
I don't answer any questions um without
a lawyer present that's why I reserve my
right to remain silent because uh people
forget that anything you say can be used
against you right but nothing you say
can be used in your defense nothing I
say anything that you brought up in
court defend you so you don't say
anything and then i've recently gotten
into this this thing where you you take
the ticket and then you do a trial by
declaration we're basically you just do
it through the mail that way you don't
have to get aboard you don't have to sit
there um I've been to court I've been to
traffic court a Sox I'm yes and it's
awful yes did a poorly run they try to
figure the hell out of us yes because
that just keeps the process moving
faster and then they can collect money
faster but here's the thing when you
actually argue in traffic court the
judges get real upset with you because
they just want to go to lunch right how
many they don't want to hear either um
in the past year i think i've had three
tickets and how many have you made i had
to pay for one of them nice i see you
okay um but i think over the past 10
years I've only had those three tickets
what have you been doing in the last
year that you've got some money I don't
know it just felt like I got busted for
like right no right turn on a school day
Wow yes alvin advice [ __ ] you don't even
know there's a school there and um it it
was like summertime so I didn't think
school is in session yeah but it's done
like private Jewish school you don't
even know when they're in session
sometimes they're not in session Monday
Tuesday Wednesday but they are thursday
friday saturday sunday is moving so you
don't know the school schedule right i
got i got a ticket for that and then I
got out of it and then some some cop
tried to pull me over saying that I
didn't yield for a pedestrian in the
crosswalk she's less mmm he gave me that
ticket but what he meant was I didn't
stop for the pedestrian in the crosswalk
but the law doesn't fastest top right
Colossus that the yield see you come
away are gonna hit this guy right and
and that's what the law says the law
says you know when you're when there's
somebody crossing the crosswalk if you
caused them to stop or cause them to
change direction somehow yeah then you
have failed the yield but this person
didn't you know didn't even change their
pace so I did a trial by declaration
where I basically admitted nothing and I
just forced I just asked a lot of
questions like can the officer prove
that I caused this person to stop or
change their pay not this big it should
be dismissed now what is eagle with you
now I stop I need you when I return that
use jigsaw to home depot and it's time I
saw dust on it and they're like did you
use this what I'm not answering any
questions now I no idea what you're
talking about yeah now one last thing if
you do feel comfortable talking about
this uh you've you've told me your
rights when you get pulled over for a
DUI um yeah first of all people don't
realize don't take any test why did you
take any test don't blow into anything
don't [ __ ] do it walking a straight
line know if they think think you've
been drinking you let them take you to
jail and take your blood sure well but
then what if that blood is over the
limit first of all you bought yourself
some time second of all they not where
they might not want to bring you in uh a
right and and if they say have you been
drinking tonight you say I don't
answer any questions where I myself
incriminate you know you're not required
to turn yourself in you're not required
to you know throw yourself under the bus
but the police kind of make it out to be
like look this is going to be easier for
everybody few cysts right just take it
in the ass come on knock knock on wood
though the two times I have been pulled
over for suspicious of DUI actually
three times I was very polite and they
let me go every three all three times
there you go whoa the court for oh this
is lucky I think it was coming back from
Sacramento I was rushing to get back to
see you tell uh-huh I was speeding I had
a beer and a shot before I they pulled
me over I blew it what is it was a point
zero eight the legal limit yeah I blew a
point zero seven and not ah but they
were like but they knew you're going to
Attell show so they knew you had to be
drunk they just they just said uh take a
half hour here in the shopping mall
parking lot and then we'll let you go
okay and then another one was fourth of
July I think had two beers like I love
America dude [ __ ] yeah I left my
headlight I had my headlights on I
turned them off cuz someone was walking
across my car as being polite yeah I'm
[ __ ] blind them I'll never do that
shitty know and they pulled me over to
black ops and how they're black no I
figured they would be everything I'm
just telling you mention that cuz it's
important I still hold you the story
like that chick so I said there would be
empathetic since I was a minority right
but that was [ __ ] so they may I do
the test and I was with sarah at the
time hold on they made you do the test
run can they make him do the test no I
make you tonight that I they trick me
into thinking it so they didn't have the
blower thing and the entire time they
thought Sarah was a prostitute like how
did you know that girl was knowing you
know where you can pull down at sure
exactly so they had Sarah dry follow us
to the station well I'm handcuffed in
the back they go so how long you know
this girl I'm like are you [ __ ]
trying to hit on my girl and then on the
way to the station they pulled over
another guy oh and a Honda Civic hey
another
Elle's full bro yeah another Asian they
arrested her they were Asian bad King
dude and trying to get your women know
their lack guy and now reinstall will
tell you you don't have to let the cops
[ __ ] your girlfriend no it's not i right
well I mean a lot of people dispute that
the cops will tell you so it's money
Sarah Sarah made a joke with after I
really she goes I would have jerked the
ball for you that's fun a good girl
you're good girl so they arrested this
other dude Oh put him in the back with
me and he was wasted Oh apparently this
guy this [ __ ] got pulled over
with his friend two miles away mm his
friend got arrested for DUI and they had
the in he drove in this [ __ ] got in
this drivers yesterday left and then
drove away they were like you idiot they
already knew yeah oh my god so went into
the station style come I was in
Minneapolis and there were people
heckling at the show friday and the club
told them that they had to leave and
they said we don't have to leave you
can't you paid for tickets and the club
is like yeah but you can't disrupt
everybody else to show and these people
are drunk in their argument is these
drunk people called the police it was
like we're gonna call the police and the
drunk people went no [ __ ] it will call
the police so what happened so so that
baked the drunks call the police the
police show I'll tell the drunks you
guys have to leave feature act is
driving home and he said yeah and get to
it pulled over they had been pulled over
by the police something that's so
[ __ ] funny cold that's so [ __ ] yeah
they probably just parked across the
street just let's just hang back and
wait for them to drive away and so Ryan
you're on stage while this is happening
uh yeah I was on stage and they were you
know I mean acne is such a great club
this so I know with some of the heckling
but I didn't deal with any of the police
got one at the back of the room it's
dark right in here anything right oh
that's good so great
them it's a mayor well listen man thanks
for picking up the phone very
entertaining and very insightful man
yeah man if you want to fight that
parking tickets you know just you could
just fight it to fight it and if they
can if they have any evidence I i might
do it just you got nothing but time just
because I got nothing but time and I
know you Ryan really quick can i buy a
fast lane ticket that there's a picture
of my car in the fast lane I could say
it wasn't a [ __ ] take the car someone
stole it no well yes I mean you you
would need some sort of evidence that
somebody stole it but you can I don't
know anything about this look at the
pictures someone else driving I don't
know anybody I know if there is your set
yeah go to court keep your mouth shut
and make them prove it was you on it's
gonna be hard would you make them mad
it's gonna be hard for me to keep my
mouth shut yeah at least your show out
here you're gonna throw yourself under
the body and then you're like your
girlfriend they gonna be like is this is
this your car what'd you [ __ ] say to
me what you think I can't afford that I
saw a guy in traffic court he had a red
light camera ticket and in this old
Russian guy and he just keeps his palms
up and he just keeps shrugging his
shoulders saying don't know I don't know
no and more judges like well sir did you
lend your car to somebody that day and I
think I don't know though this picture
looks like you do you have is there
somebody else in your family who might
look like you and he cuz I don't know
she can you show me a picture on your
ponos any family member who looks like
you and he just goes no I don't I don't
have anything and she if she just looks
defeated because he keeps just shrugging
it yeah all right there this case ah
Oh [ __ ] eyes and I'm saying that's
why Paul Ryan genius I I just gave the
city of santa clarita jump almost 400
[ __ ] dollar no no no I like we got
all these rights and anion sound nose
along dude i love it i don't know i
don't know just be a pain in their ass
until they're like you know what just
get your ball and go home yeah yeah yeah
great just you just keep asking for
things from court asked for you know I
need to know who's prosecuting me and
there they would say I always go why do
you need that information you know it's
my sixth amendment oh ok it's [ __ ]
t-ball ok I I go in and have a hard time
that's great dude that's all so this is
this is a very interesting segment we
might have to call you in the future
about about things hopefully we won't we
won't need advice on the law but maybe
we'll have to tell you again oh my god
great talking to you thank you so much
to you all right let out here right see
that's what I'd like I've ran on the
phone he's so great on us out he's one
of the funniest guys on the planet dude
and you don't know Craig he show up he
always wears seems familiar he always
wears a suit ok and so he's a really
funny guy does he wear like an old-timey
suits and even no no no no no no he
wears like the legit suits like he plays
this character like he's smarter than
everybody and is he has a Jeselnik Tosh
kind of feel like like even little
Stephen Colbert thrown in there like he
doesn't diminish what he does he's very
very here's the thing is like uh I know
I started a stout in San Francisco okay
this year time I've amazed how low he
was on the phone cuz doing phone podcast
/ interviews stuff sure it's tough he
was very good at yeah you know he might
replace Wendell Jesus Christ it's like
such different ends of the spectrum uh
does anyone have to go can we call
Wendell or do you have to go I I got in
my leaps you i have a three clock that's
all Joe we've done so much time yeah we
um and why don't window all right oh
yeah I know who this guy is who Oh Ryan
stout yeah yeah he's not he's really
cool you able to
we met up on the floor yeah he's
somebody on the fourth that's right it's
with a view see so worth an ant a
blackberry like this do should just kill
themselves like it lily is so judgey
we're so judgey with phones now I suck
well this this one's starting to fail on
me okay would it be weird to steal
Matt's phone as a friend yeah I think it
looks it off duty of course Ryan
probably know how to get you off right
just deny it did did did did anyone see
me take the phone whose process can you
prove it alright this case is dismissed
I like that who's prosecuting this is a
traffic ticket prosecutor that's my am i
right it's my sixth amendment sixth
amendment right my favorite show and do
ride my could be a lawyer so he sounds
like his girlfriend's father's a lawyer
they talk shop all the time yeah what's
up please leave me a message holy
Barracuda sounds like robot Steve I love
ya hey sugar pants um he's probably
working yeah yeah probably he's doing
this thing we're like first of all he's
pretending like he didn't just bum-rush
the podcast last week pretended like he
didn't will by not texting me back
uh-huh like he doesn't have his phone on
him he's playing this I'm too busy you
didn't give me enough notice he doesn't
like being on the phone yeah can we can
we accept that because did he not just
show up uninvited to the house sure yast
week yeah it was a good surprise at
school by the way the neighbor was like
I love this wendell he's really great
i'm like red flag red flag red flag
alright that's gonna do it for us with a
full charge power hour check out kevin
shea at kevin shea comedy on twitter a
comedy and check out my new pie up now
paul gas youtube show Shea speak every
tuesday thursday che speak all right
yeah craig coleman at team coleman 76 um
Matt fulchiron I have a podcast called a
full charge power hour check it out you
should lay it
earth